we dare you may viossat un langage de
sorciers qui emprunte au latin jk
rowling a parsemé ses ouvrages de
référence antique des emprunts qui ont
donné envie à la romancière blandine le
callet d'en faire un ouvrage sur une
idée soufflée par ces étudiants et déjà
il ya beaucoup de noms de professeur qui
font directement référence à des à des
dieux du panthéon grec ou romain le
professeur mcgonagall s'appelle minerva
séminaire va athéna la déesse de la
sagesse est aussi une déesse guerrière
et lorsqu est intéressant évidemment
c'est que les nonces s'agit pas
simplement d'eux d'emprunter des noms
c'est que la personnalité des
personnages qui les portes sont aussi en
accord avec les dieux leurs homonymes
antique une démarche de vulgarisation
qui s'inscrivait dans le premier
festival des langues classiques organisé
par la ville de versailles
au coeur de cette édition la
transmission des racines pour comprendre
sa culture versailles son château cette
ville est une ville qui s'est construit
conçu dans le dans une logique de
référence à l'antique un nul suffit de
se promener dans les jardins du château
de versailles pour voir ses statuts qui
sont pour beaucoup d'entre elles des
copies identiques le néoclassicisme né à
la cour une vingtaine de rendez vous
animés par des chercheurs des historiens
et des romanciers pour dépoussiérer
l'image des langues
mais j'aime bien
la lithologie et
oui ça permet justement de faire
vraiment le lien entre aujourd'hui et
les langues anciennes et montrer que ça
sert encore aujourd'hui et que c'est
important la culture antique encore
aujourd'hui le festival a attiré près de
2000 passionnés les organisateurs
réfléchissent déjà à la seconde édition